congratulations season 14. it's coming
and victory never tasted so sweet
so who did you guys clock as the biggest
competition day one in the work room
daya
and jiria
and jeria came into the competition with
like such finesse and boys
and she was just one of those people
that i could tell right off the bat i
was going to keep my eye on
so the moment she started speaking and
she started being funny i was like this
[ __ ] is a double triple threat
quadruple threat now let's make it shake
honey i would say angie as soon as angie
came in i was like okay it's a pageant
girl she's got outfits and then i heard
her speed and i was like oh hell she has
a big personality too
alyssa look it didn't even take me no
time y'all you're looking out right now
you see what i mean i took one of her
and i was like
excuse me thank you
thank you steve i love you
you will see
my biggest competition at the beginning
um was cornbread because
she had this huge personality when they
opened up that box of chocolate they
ain't gonna be what they thought it was
i would say cornbread
because i you know i knew her around la
and i went to college with her so i knew
her performance background she has that
ability when she's in the room you you
want to listen to her you want to laugh
with her you want to be friends with her
and so i was like well i got to watch
out for this beach i have to agree i've
got to say cornbread i think just from
day one i was like nobody can match the
energy level that cornbread breaks like
i think that she
is so like
just well-rounded like she is a star
thank you y'all so sweet i was gonna say
cornbread you seem surprised by that
what does it mean to hear those words i
think we're so hard on ourselves as drag
queens or just entertainers drag kings
drag performers or drag artists in
general we're so hard on ourselves about
things and our peers are like the
closest people to us so when you hear
stuff about yourself from their view it
kind of you know uh humbles you a lot
and i'll get you a little mushy i'm not
gonna cry though because um i got my
tear ducts removed but
that means a lot to me does that truly
does all right so obviously you know
this season the show casts for the first
time a cisgender hetero queen i'm
curious if anyone had any reactions to
that casting when they first heard about
it and also what was the experience like
once you actually got to work with
maddie yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna kind of
step in here just because i had known
maddie before the competition i actually
had worked with her a couple of times
and i was just happy because
rupaul says it literally every time that
drag is literally just what you put on
your body anybody can do drag and it's
an art form i think people need to learn
the separation between
drag as an art form and it's not just
something for a certain group of people
where paul says we go in naked and the
rest distracts so when we were first in
the room it wasn't something that was
just thrown at us like oh here's this
here's that it was more like getting to
know people and through that i was like
oh wow that's a story i also you know
being the woman that i am was like you
know you got a girlfriend
choose your shot girl
okay i had to you can go trade on the
season i think the drag is for everyone
and i'm just so proud to see that
someone stepped up to the plate from
outside
of the typical demographic same year and
kind of just went with it and gave it
their all and i was like yes honey when
i first met maddie i was honestly not
gonna lie i was pretty gagged i was gag
like house down because
who like you never really see this
anywhere but the fact but meeting her
and actually like getting to know her
like as a person oh my god one of the
most funniest people that i met and i
think it's like super important for like
especially in our community exactly well
and i think that a lot of people you
know want to preach inclusivity like in
our community and i think that you know
we that includes allies as well and i
think you know we have to come to a
point where we realize that you know
drag is for everybody just like with
movies or books like
people can write a book people can write
movies people can design something and
it's their form of self-expression and i
think like everybody is welcome to that
maddie i want to turn things over to you
what was your reaction when you heard
the news that you'd be on the show no i
mean
getting the call is obviously like the
the moment that's like your life is
gonna change i was super excited about
it super terrified but even just putting
in the audition tape in general is just
such like a milestone it just takes so
much like courage to put yourself
out on that level you know um
i honestly like it just like it went
from the realization of my life is going
to change to me like panic mode of like
i have to get all my drag together i
have to get out i have to get ready for
this lady camden were you surprised by
the reaction to this casting
by the reaction i mean honestly when i
first you know met maddie and when we
were all together um my my thought
didn't really kind of go to that as much
until
the announcement was made and then i
realized oh there's such a big
conversation happening which is great um
but
yeah my first thought in the moment was
like this is going to be a sickening
class because it's super
and like we have incredible stories to
tell
[Music]